[音楽]
超日焼けしちゃうこんにちははじめしゃ
ちょーです
皆さんはサウナというものをご存知
でしょうかもう今やここ数年でですね人々
に寄り添う存在になってしまったサウナ
ここまで
注目されるかと言わんばかりの
驚きの
普及率今や趣味は何ですかと聞いてサウナ
と答える人かなり多いと思いますそんな
サウナなんですけれども私はじめ社長は
もう自宅この4億円ハウスの自宅にサウナ
を作りましたそれはもう快適極まりない
ですよこの超高級サウナチェア生命の源で
ある水風呂シャワーみんなで整えるように
整い椅子そしてここが
[音楽]
の4件のサウナなんですけれどもサウナに
大事な要素いろいろあるんですよまあもう
ごめんなさいねサウナーの皆さんからする
とこんなのはもう当たり前でしょみたいな
今さら言うなと思うと思うんですけれども
サウナに大事な要素いくつかあります
もちろん言わずもがなサウナの温度それも
僕があのクリアしてると思っております
うちのさんは110度まで上がるので
サウナの温度はOKそしてただ暑いところ
に入る苦しいだけがサウナではございませ
ん水風呂水風呂もいい感じに冷え冷えの水
が出てますまあオッケーでしょうここも
クリアしてると思いますあとね
臭いとかなんですよ匂いなんかそのアロマ
の水とか入れてやるとすごいいい香りがし
たりしてこれもねめっちゃヒノッキーの
香りが中にしてめちゃくちゃ匂い持ってる
完璧なんですよ最高なかったかまた足り
ない
サウナにおいてとても大事な要素
湿度でございますこれねワンちゃんね温度
より大事だと思いますねかの有名な静岡県
にあるサウナ式辞さんあると思いますあと
サウナが2つあるんですよフィンランド
サウナと薬草サウナという2つあるんです
けども私共に薬草サーの使わせて頂いて
おりますフィンランドサウナの方が温度が
100°c超えてて結構熱いと思いきや実
は
薬草サウナ60°から70°cの薬草
サウンドの方が熱いこれなぜか湿度なん
ですよ
猿さん
友達のサウナジャンキーを呼んできました
今日よろしくお願いしますお願いします
サウナ式辞とかどうですか
薬草サウナとフィンランドサウナがあると
思うんですけれども
温度だけ見るとやっぱフィンランドの方が
高いじゃないですかそうですね
薬草は60度ぐらいマジでわかってるなの
に体感温度なぜか薬草の方が高いこれなぜ
かわかりますか
湿度ですマジでわかってんじゃないか
ありがとうございますだから普通のサウナ
でもあのサウナストーンのところにお水を
かけて料理をして水が蒸発してバーって
なってサウナ室内の湿気をガーっと上げる
ことによって体感温度が全然変わってくる
んですよカラカラの110度と
ビチャビチャの110度全然違うだから
敷地はすごいんです60度から70度でも
すごく熱く感じでも耐えられないぐらいの
温度が再現できてるつまりサウナによって
湿度すごい大事なんですよね皆さん想像し
てみてくださいカラカラに熱い人地面詰め
の暑い日どっちが辛いか
ジメジメの熱い木の方が多分汗とかき
やすいし体幹が全然違うんですよそんな
湿度も一応我が家ストーンもあるので
ローリングセットあってこうやっていつも
かけてね
熱くしてるわけなんですけども
まだ足りませんまだ足りません必要なもの
あります
風邪です皆さんはネットパスという言葉ご
存知でしょうか知ってますかはい聞いた
ことありますまだ体験したことはないん
です
ないです
お前今日死ぬぞマジでマジですかちょっと
準備しておきなさいサウナストーンで水
かけて蒸気がバーって出てそれを体に向け
て熱いやつになるのが気持ちいいんです
けれどもただ湧き出てるのをそのまま放置
するんじゃなくてそれを風邪とかで
熱波でぶっ飛ばし室長に当ててやき殺す
これが熱しなんですよ湿度+風でその
蒸気を体に当てる熱波がいるとより熱く
感じるのでネパールは人気なんですよね
そうなんです私のお家の足りないものは
何か
風邪でしたというわけでなんか
熱っとかそのアウトブースとかいろんな
方法で風を送る手段はあるんですけれども
最強のれっぱし見つけましたこちらです
どうぞ
[音楽]
超
巨大扇風機ですもうこの送風機超巨大扇風
機を使ってもう人では時速可能なできない
ぐらいの強風を送り続けることによって
ぶっ飛ぶんじゃないかっていう110度で
風を送ったら普通にもうあの僕今日終わり
かもしれません
ぶっ飛ぶ可能性があるんですけれども今日
はそんな超巨大扇風機をお家のサウナに
ぶち込んでマジで史上最強がサウナを作っ
てみたいと思います私の予想ですと体感
温度おそらく300超えますね
怖いですじゃあ早速準備していきましょう
でかい扇風機あるにはあるんですけど
サウナ
室まで人の力だと持ち上げられませんでし
た重すぎてなのでもう業者さんに頼んでも
レッカーで持ち上げてもらうしかなくて今
こんなことになってます
[音楽]
[笑い]
すごい光景だ
[音楽]
やばいねこれ
お金のかかるこれ本当重いんですよね
[音楽]
絶対ね
暑すぎることはもう分かってるので先に
冷たい
キンキンの水風呂が待ってますはいという
わけで俺のサウナゾーンに超巨大送風機
囲うことができました
衝撃の高さのクレーンを使って運ぶことが
できましたありがとうございました皆さん
これはすごいですよもちろん
熱っよりすごいというかもうジャンルが
違うのでそこを比較することすら愚かただ
1個わかるのはネパスよりも長く体力無限
なので
永遠に
熱い熱波を送り続けることができる
史上最強の熱っ
[拍手]
ハリケーン梅宮ですハリケーン皆さん今日
よろしくお願いしますというわけで早速
設置していきましょうそもそもどう設置
するかがここからが問題です
[音楽]
ぶつかります
ダメです
え
終わりました皆さん最悪です入りません
サウナスに持ち込めませんハリケーン海や
がこれ絶対無理だよねもうこれ
多分無理だ1回どかそうぜ
そうありがとうございましたこの動画が
良ければグッドボタン高評価チャンネル
登録よろしくお願いしますでまた次の動画
でお会いしましょうバイバイ
そうだこれだけでかい送風機サウナルーム
に運べるわけがない諦めません私はもう1
個コンパクトだけど強力な総復帰準備し
ました持ってきます
持ってきましたこんなんじゃこの企画は
終わりませんこれなら運び込めるであろう
サイズの送付金準備しましたとりあえず
これ一回近くまで持ってきましょう
完了しましたこの位置に置くことによって
直でサウナ室に最強の風を送りつけること
ができますそしてさらにここから風を
送りつける作戦です直接風を送れないので
2台体制でいきますこの送風機で風をぐっ
とまとめて強力な体がこっちに送りその風
をこのピンポイントな強力な装置で
まとめ上げて
サウナ室にぶち込むとどうでしょうこの
作戦
温度は今109°c
間違いなしでは早速
史上最強の熱波を呼んだはじめしゃちょー
の4億円サウナ入っていきたいと思います
暑いいやもうそもそも110度の時点で
結構やばいです
やばいわもうこの時点で結構暑いですね
ただここからさらに熱くなりますよお願い
します
[音楽]
これをぶっかけてからかけてからの本番
よ
なんか冷たい風が来るんだ
はい皆さん衝撃の事実が分かりました
サウナ室の扉を開けたまま送風機2つも
つけると
意味がない意味がないことが分かりました
暑いのよ全然熱いんですけれどももう俺
なんかちょっとした110度だったら
耐えれる体のサウナーになってるんで
なんかそんな響かなかったと言いますか
言い方悪いですけど扉開けてるのが非常に
ダメだなと思いましたねはいもう水風呂に
入る必要はないぐらいの厚さと言いますか
というわけですすいませんあの多分この
送風にでかすぎて入らないのでこれはもう
ダメですダメなんですけれども逆にこれ
密室で小さい方の送風機を中に入れてドア
閉めてつければ1あるんじゃないかと思い
ましてちょっとそっちの方向でやってみ
たいと思います
これなら外気の冷たい風を持ってこない
そしてドア閉めちゃえばいってことでしょ
[音楽]
こういうことだろう
見たことないよこれ
扉をお願いします
命の危険を感じるんだわかりました
逃げ道はないかな行きます
あーやばい
しまっちゃってるのはすごい大事っぽいな
じゃあ行きましょうか
密封サウナー巨大送風機
スタートお願いします321
[音楽]
やばいこれやばい
これやばいこれ
言ってることでやってることが矛盾し
ちゃうそれがサウナー
しました
やばい
やばいやばい
なんでこの手は止まらないんだ俺は止め
られないんだ
すごいすごい
止めて止めてやばいやばいやばい大丈夫か
お前もなんかやばそうやばいやばい
[音楽]
これね結構やばかったね
なんか俺足の子ないもんもうやっぱその
湿度が高いところで出す風邪ってネップ
暑い日のさ強い風めっちゃ痛いじゃんか
なってるやつそれと同じ原理でもう
熱風ってめちゃくちゃ体熱くなるんですよ
それは今室内でやっちゃいけない大きさの
扇風機回したんでなんか普通に記憶ない
ですね
[音楽]
もう1回入るか
OK
よしじゃあもう1回入りたいと思います
仲間を連れて
安田さんどうぞ
痩せるから確かにね
[拍手]
[音楽]
これやばいわ
皆さん
ようこそ
[音楽]
今日はこちらのビッグバン岡村さんがね
パスを務めさせていただきますよろしくお
願いしますお願いしますじゃあ行きます
お願いします
失礼します
[音楽]
[拍手]
悪くない
皆さん体幹何度ぐらいですか
風があるとねその早いですよね熱の周りが
多分国内まれに見るならできたんじゃない
かなと思います
じゃあもう1セットいきましょう
[音楽]